actually pandemonium
what is life without its body what are
the beings of the net if not
souls from beyond our plane of existence
i have heard their voices let they who
yet live
never cross that threshold for their
souls will join those ghostly ranks
you know i've been in cyberspace and i
did actually meet a corpse or two there
hark the witness testify of those who
burn in hellfire yeah didn't see that
fire though
you ask who opened these unholy gates of
the abyss
no one's asking and i answer you
the techno necromancers of alpha
centauri
i recognize you you come here often
your eyes tell me that your mind has
opened to the truth
will you provide a humble donation so
that i may continue my mission
oh yeah and do good work use this to
wake night city up
thank you for your devotion i saw a
disciple of truth in you from the very
beginning
oh i
my life
scratch
ah [ __ ]
they traverse the badlands and trucks
yes but when the full moon rises
they remove their human masks and what
hides underneath you ask
reptilians answer you no
not reptilians but werewolves
at sunset they strip off their clothes
and dance
nakedly giving in to an animalistic
ecstasy
then once they've transformed into the
fanged beasts
they set off on the hunt hungry for
human flesh
dozens of miles they cover in the
darkness with ferocious speed
like arrows in the night
met my share of nomads and there's
definitely something primal about him
those cannibal claims crossed the line
though deny the truth
all you want but what will you do when
the pack
hunts you down and the cause behind
these monstrous horrors
years ago a ship from alpha centauri
crash landed in the badlands legend
tells that it carried a substance highly
sought after by the vampire elite
in arasaka it could transform saburo's
enemies into werewolves
leashed and bound to his will but the
crash
you've got a problem with nomads freak
better shut your fat [ __ ] mouth
before i put your six feet under
you can break my bones but you cannot
stop the pursuit of truth
i've had enough of this guy last thing
we need is this level of crazy staying
in the streets
[ __ ] him up maybe that'll teach him a
real lesson
[ __ ] talk nomad and that's what you get
choose
oh
so
move
[Music]
kerry hey got any eating plants
cancel come the dark matter on woodland
might not know the place
they don't really advertise what's the
occasion
no occasion [ __ ] wipes from us cracks
screw me over
still want to do the cover even have
their lawyers send me a [ __ ]
restraining order
can you imagine like i'd even want to
bring this
up [ __ ] carrie i'm sorry
don't worry still helped a lot anyway
swing by the club back door don't be
late
thank you
oh